previously on TV sentence boldface or
toothless toothless could have sworn you
had teeth episode begins with dramatic
eye ball opening cliche I know
television that's a television and we
have to have music cues swelling up all
over the joint but can we pick an image
a little more interesting than a pink
shoe that looks like it was hung up in
the same way a sock would be put on a
dorm room doorknob Jack could just be
running into some plane crash survivors
feeling lucky to be alive and horny as
hell also if this shoe was thrown out of
the plane during the crash I was gonna
get caught by its lace on this story
there's really nothing here to even snag
and at that velocity it would more
likely fray the lace than catch it I'm
thankful that characters changed pretty
drastically from the pilot since it's
usually written separately because I
might not be able to handle much more
Shannon if she doesn't she doesn't relie
become less annoying right Damon
Carlton will someone please answer me
they survived this or did they I've
heard the classic question is there a
doctor on board and there's always a
good chance one yes however the chances
of having a surgeon as skilled as jack
on this flight and surviving is a hell
of a lot narrower flight eight one five
is lucky as fantastic mr. Fox here
wasn't just a dentist chiropractor or
corpse agreed but also how long is that
engine gonna keep spinning and operating
at normal deadly speed now that it
doesn't appear to be connected to all
the other parts of the plane this one's
on lock right that did was just running
by until you made him stop right in
front of the damn thing I'm on Team
random guy who's about to be cutting the
tiny pieces here jack Rose a large
vessel crashing into pieces yeah no
worries I'm pretty sure her heart will
go on old habits die hard I guess I
don't know so let me get this straight
loony moons you were told to go get a
pen and even though we knew it was a
wild goose chase you thought it was to
save someone's life yet instead of
running the first pen you found
immediately back to the actively dying
person you found what for more before
you decided to head back also Jack isn't
even in the same location now so
wouldn't you have run there first and
seen that Rose was no longer in need
Kerry just sew that up it's just like
the drapes wish I'm with Kate here you
asked her if she'd ever used a needle
and now you know she's only used a
sewing machine if you're going to just
have her sew you up no matter what
anyway why even ask the question
stand there black that's threaded very
few shows have done character work as
beautifully and efficiently as lost in
less than two minutes of almost
worthless Beach position we get the vibe
of Sawyer Claire
Hurley Locke boon Sayid Charlie Andros
eight characters and the time most shows
would take to do one plus instead of
stuffing us with backstory it makes us
hungry no no more ha
damn this might be one of the best hours
of television ever also time for an
unexpected top 5 list top 5 best hours
of television in all history in random
order the loss premiere Breaking Bad
Ozymandias Star Trek the next
generations inner light Game of Thrones
hardhome and The Sopranos Pine Barrens
discuss when I was in residency my first
solo procedure was a spinal surgery on a
16 year old kid you do have a needle
going in and out of your skin with zero
anesthesia though right how are you
telling the story as if you're sitting
back in the airport bar so it ripped
open and the nerves just spilled out of
her like angel hair pasta you had me at
it ripped open you had me at it ripped
open
also keep just said I might turn off my
head so maybe the story isn't such a
great idea we must have been at about
40,000 feet when it happened hit an air
pocket in the original script Jack was
supposed to be the pilot my guess is
this was dialog he was supposed to say
in that script because there's no
[ __ ] way Jack the surgeon would know
this with any certainty also I'm a huge
fan of anyone who after a long day of
death to stress and trauma all around
them with the limited tools of a
stranded Island environment only found
by sifting through the burning wreckage
of their previous life makes the effort
to craft a perfect airplane shape out of
a palm leaf just for the sake of
visually explaining to another person
that I blacked out totally worth it I
saw some smoke just a valley
did it look mean or angry to you like
say a monster lost confirms early on
that it will be at least 40% blowing
smoke I was weird right is that Vincent
I'm not a hundred percent on Walt's age
here but he looks at least knows the
difference between a dog bark and a
mysterious giant tree shaking growl
years old to me terrific
damn straight
don't tell anyone should be easy no one
is sitting next to him the seat front
right of him looks empty asked us the
seat directly behind him he's so
isolated it's a wonder she even felt the
need to give a warning
someone has clearly seen that Godfather
also looking passed down creepy this
whole gesture is who the feets an orange
like this jack in the mystery box here
has a point in fact why did either the
other two have to climb this plane at
all he's the one who has the transceiver
knowledge right so what are the
transceiver look like complicated walkie
talkie so what does a complicated
walkie-talkie look like we can play this
game all day or you can quit being a
condescending dick just in case you
don't realize you're watching a JJ
Abrams pilot episode Greg Grunberg pops
in to say hi wonder if he'll just happen
to have some information our castaways
need also not having him wear a red
shirt of some kind seems like a missed
opportunity no smoke shadowing what
happened sir Charles is that this kind
gentleman here had expositor Devery
thing he needed to so he was disposed of
you know kind of like how you throw away
an empty tube of preparation H when it's
done SOI fer guys how does something
like that happen the show does not
include the predator
what's in the box oh no he died you're
gonna be okay I'm gonna be okay
say the goddamn word I'm blacked out I
know what people taste like I know that
babies taste best you all everybody
singing well it's no wonder you don't
have any friends that's gonna leave a
mark
we have to go back for him we have to go
back Kate
we have to go back